well brian a wayward golf shot was the  catalyst for a series of events  that ended with one man dead that's  according to a complaint filed by the  prince law group citing an incident at  legacy golf club  now the complaint says that daniel saws  was shot while playing there with  friends back in april  a golf ball hit a neighboring home and  51-year-old clarence jackson  came out threw the ball back at the  group but he hit one of them in the face  jackson allegedly came back out with a  gun and accidentally fired around  hitting sauls but that's when jackson  went back inside  and took his own life sauls is seeking  more than 60 thousand dollars in damages  for that shooting